[Applauso]
buongiorno a tutti oggi voglio
raccontarvi una storia
oggi voglio parlarvi dal mio amico marco
marco si sentiva solo solo con la sua
timidezza
solo con i problemi di un adolescente
che si trova ad affrontare la vita solo
con se stesso
chiuso nella cameretta della sua anima
che non riusciva e non voleva più a
nessuno
fuori lì dove la primavera gioca con gli
altri e dove il sole e l'amico di tutti
marco non trovavo un posto libero su
quella panchina affiancato un amico con
cui parlare non vedevo uno spiraglio di
luce se non quella che gli altri usavano
per proiettare le sue visioni
gli altri gente senza volto e forse
senza anima gli altri che lo criticavano
senza conoscerlo che devastavano la sua
anima senza aver mai provato ad entrarci
senza nemmeno essersi mai fermati
sull'uscio
marco decise quindi di rifugiarsi una
sua intimità
decide di rifugiarsi nei social i social
quell angolo remoto lontano dal mondo
lontano da tutte le panchine relazionali
dove crede di poter inanellare le sue
emozioni
i suoi sentimenti e le sue opinioni
crede
marco si rifugia nei social perché li
trovava le sue panchine relazionali
alcune colorate altri grigie gli pareva
un modo indolore per esorcizzare la sua
solitudine
forse un escamotage per immaginare quel
fluido magico che scorre tra un'opinione
e il suo contrario
non capisce però che lo schermo il
monitor di oscuro alle emozioni gli
copre la mimica
lo smartphone di ultima generazione
entra nelle nostre vite ma in realtà
cos'è è solo un'illusione che trasforma
una somma di grafemi in una sorta di
comunicazione senza lo sguardo complice
delle emozioni
il nostro marco saprebbe e vorrebbe
parlare ma ha bisogno di quel muro quel
muro luminoso attraverso il quale riesce
ad essere sempre e solo io
ed ecco
il primo social della storia fu six
degrees ma il primo a prendere il nome
di social network fu friendster nato nel
marzo del 2002 su quelle già si potevano
condividere foto video messaggi come il
nostro instagram
ebbene sì venti anni fa
iniziano a prendere i piedi social
iniziano ad entrare nelle nostre vite
senza che ce ne accorgessimo
oggigiorno tutti noi usiamo i mezzi
tecnologici per comunicare tutti noi
mandiamo un messaggio su whatsapp
facciamo gli auguri di buon compleanno i
nostri amici su facebook poi stiamo foto
e video su instagram
tutti quanti quotidianamente lo facciamo
tutti chi più e chi meno ed è diventato
un'azione talmente abitudinaria che
ormai non ci facciamo più attenzione ce
ne accorgiamo paradossalmente solo
quando non possiamo farlo quando ad
esempio il nostro telefono e scarico
oppure non abbiamo internet siamo
immersi in questa nuova realtà così come
un palombaro si immergerete dei fondi
marini per cercare tesori nascosti
ma noi cos'è che cerchiamo veramente noi
stessi
oppure un modo per sentirci meno soli
al di là di quello schermo ci sono
milioni di panchine relazionali di
luoghi di prossimità estendono le
barriere del tempo e dello spazio
nel mondo di oggi l'immediatezza diventa
un valore e il tempo che sempre incalza
diventa lo sconfitto nella pista delle
occasioni
basti pensare a quando si è diventati
immediata comunicare qualsiasi cosa
prima si usavano lettere che dal tempo
di spedizione fino alla risposta
richiedevano giorni settimane e mesi di
tempo oggi basta meno di un secondo
provate ad immaginare il mondo il secolo
scorso anzi 40 50 anni fa a veri amici
al di fuori dal proprio quartiere della
propria città del proprio paese era
qualcosa di insolito
oggi invece la comunicazione virtuale ci
permette di ampliare la nostra cerchia
di amici in maniera esponenziale
riuscendo a stringere rapporti con
persone dall'altra parte del mondo
i social danno a tutti l'opportunità di
dire la propria opinione i social danno
a tutti l'occasione di trovare l'anima
gemella
oppure il mico perfetto che sa ascoltare
c essa capirci che esso sia in cina in
america o in qualsiasi altra parte del
mondo
in particolare durante l'ultimo periodo
durante il quale tutti eravamo confinati
nelle nostre abitazioni si è capito
quanto veramente facessero importanti
per uccidere la solitudine in quanti di
noi in questa sala durante il lock down
abbiamo scaricato apcom e oss parti
abbiamo passato intere notti a parlare
faccia a faccia coi nostri amici come ce
l'avessimo di fronte
però come esiste il giorno esiste anche
la notte esistono le cose più belle gli
aspetti più affascinanti ed intriganti
di questo mondo e ciò che riesce a
rovinarlo completamente ovviamente
dipende tutto dall'uso che se ne fa
prima ho detto che i social danno una
possibilità a tutti questa è una cosa
bella è una cosa positiva
però tanto quanto negativa poiché
ovviamente c'è chi ne fa un uso
improprio
essendo a portare di tutti i social nei
social tutti possono dire la propria
opinione
però
talvolta non si comprenda la differenza
tra opinione e giudizio poiché dietro da
una tastiera può prender voce la parte
peggiore di ognuno
questo perché è più facile nascondersi
dietro una foto o ad un nome che non è
il nostro per denigrare chi
all'apparenza sembra più debole
le violenze del bullo precedentemente
erano più fisica che psicologica
mentre i social hanno accentuato quelle
psicologiche
infatti oggi si parla sempre più di
sempre bullismo che di bullismo i famosi
leonida tastiera assillano con
incessanti prese in giro il ragazzo
diverso
il ragazzo strano come può sembrare è un
ragazzo sovrappeso per un ragazzo timido
tre vantaggi già citati prima
occupa un ruolo fondamentale la velocità
con la quale vengono diffuse le
informazioni ma con altrettanta velocità
vengono divulgate le famose fake news
che alle volte sono innocue ma possono
diventare vere e proprie valanghe di
cattiva informazione pseudo certezze
comunicare al tempo dei social è un modo
per uccidere la solitudine per tutti l
entrata nell immenso supermarket della
conoscenza per molti è un modo per
allargare gli orizzonti e trovare nuove
panchine relazionali così come non
supermarket ci si entra per acquistare
ciò che ci serve
i social m a nostra disposizione un
bagaglio culturale immenso che a lungo
andare ha sostituito abitudini ormai
tramontate come sfogliare un giornale
consultarono enciclopedie un libro
il tutto ciò di cui soffrivamo prima per
ricchi il nostro bagaglio culturale
per dissetare la nostra sete di
coscienza e ormai automatico aprire
google di citare ciò che vogliamo sapere
e con un click ci troviamo di fondato un
mare di informazioni
la domanda quindi sorge spontanea i
social possono essere considerati come
un'evoluzione
oppure sono considerabili solo come un
involuzione appena scelta grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]